I've yet to see it in action I love
playing airsoft for those who don't know
airsoft is kinda like paintball
except you shoot little plastic BBS
instead of paintballs I've been wanting
to make like a massive airsoft gun that
just blasts like a hundred babies
downrange it's going to be as many
working gas blowback pistols as we have
in the office stack together it sounds
like a good concept for a video so we're
gonna build it hopefully it works
hopefully don't break our guns and then
we're going to test it oh I'm gonna film
it all in slow motion when it happens
you know the ironic part about working
here at corridor is I don't I don't like
guns I'm willing to bet none of these
work how many pistols do we have we got
eight thirteen eighteen twenty to thirty
thirty four thirty eight forty airsoft
pistols and we have no idea how many
work and we have to find out which ones
work this guns like completely broken it
doesn't have a magazine this gun should
just be thrown away half of these guns
have a BB lodged in them no don't you
mean there was a baby okay
[Music]
well you guys saying that we're
mistreating these guns you're right
I don't give up sorry 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
through all the pistols ever good find I
don't have that many I mean these are
all jank and don't work so we have 11
guns right now that are functional how
many do you and Sam have in your
personal stash yeah you tell me we just
have guns hidden yeah yeah you guys know
that rent is branded he's a brand on him
it's just one of those like hardware
store Essex heat it up and want like a
fireplace no a blowtorch I have been
thinking a little bit about like how we
actually mount all the guns up to be
able to pull the trigger on all them at
the same time so instead of sliding a
rod through all of the trigger holes
let's put strings attached to all the
trigger holes and put those onto a rod
get the rod in a certain place and we
can tie each string individually until
it's taut pull the rod and it'll pull
all the strings at the same time
might take a little bit of set-up time
to build it I've been wanting to make a
airsoft blaster for a long time 13 14 15
16 16 guns alright so now we need to
build a rig for all this you start with
that process ran you are the engineering
mastermind here you're on your own
you're abandoning me right now I have to
go film video games it's gonna be janky
that's what I like to hear hey guys
thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video because without them we
wouldn't be able to make smeller that's
right as I told you in the last video
what we've done is gone out and created
the world's first take a picture and
find out what it smells like app that's
right and with their beautiful
award-winning templates that are
flexible for any kind of website we made
smeller and it's fantastic okay we took
it up to Silicon Valley just last week
we met with some joint venture
capitalists they told us that our
foundational technology you know it
might be fundamentally terrible but I
think we're gonna be past that in about
three to six months and I got to say
we're gonna bring it back to them
they're gonna be real excited if you
guys are looking to make a smeller of
your own consider Squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform that you never have
to update and of course it's got 24/7
customer service so how
over to squarespace.com / Sam and Nico
and you get 10% of your first purchase
also be on the lookout for the next
iteration of smeller
smell-a-vision brand-new day brand-new
wood we're gonna go make a mount for all
these guns
we are gonna basically just use one of
these as a board that all the guns will
be mounted on and then the other half of
the board will chop into small little
parts yeah big and then just screw this
into the other board so what you'll end
up with is just like it'll look like a
comb kind of like a giant comb made out
of two by fours so that's step one right
is to make the comb lay out of the frame
and then we'll attach all the guns
probably just using gaff tape but we
also have to find out some sort of way
to mount this so that it doesn't fall
over
have you ever shot a gun once the rig is
complete yeah okay so I've rigged the
first two guns up and now I'm just gonna
test them to see if they actually work
safety is off on both guns we are live
three two one nice it works now we're
just gonna put all the rest of the guns
on
are we doing ran we're doing alright the
1911's have like this little grip safety
feature that you have to be holding it
in order for it to fire it's just like a
little switch at the back here so I'm
just kind of going along and uh taping
those clothes and this time I'm going to
make sure I don't hold down the trigger
while I do it this is even crazier than
the spinning gun rig from Breaking Bad I
don't know about that that was pretty
crazy and that actually killed people
fictionally anyway before you start
clacking away on your keyboard
ridiculing us for our gun safety know
that I agree with you this is absurd we
have all the guns mounted we have all
the strings attached now we got to
figure out the trigger mechanism and
what we've devised here is actually just
taking an entire piece of 2x4 we're
gonna attach these door hinges just like
this the purpose of that is so that it
can rotate around a fixed point as
opposed to just arbitrarily pulling on
it and maybe I pull a little bit too
much on this side rather than here we
might get some inconsistent trigger
pulls so the hinges will keep it
entirely consistent along the entire
board here so I can just rotate back ah
and fire all the guns at once the last
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna put
screws into each of these things here so
that we can wrap the string around and
then secure this in place so that way
they're relying on the screw to be the
acting point for the string rather than
take I'm starting get excited man I
think this is gonna work really well I
went to YouTube mmm I say that our days
are never the same here at corridors but
I think my favorite part is after all
the stress and the planning and getting
a video shoot ready when you wake up on
that shoot day and you get there and you
get your first shot off that's the best
part we wanted to do a new format that
would allow for us to experiment with
things this format is a great way to do
that because it's regular it allows for
you to have a crazy idea and go hey this
is something I want to try I don't know
if it's gonna work but we're gonna try
it if I could only use one lens for the
rest of my life I would choose a nice 50
millimeter prime lens that
bends to at least 1/5 you don't get a
lot of warping on the sides and it's not
like a extreme telephoto lens work
compresses the space too much it's a
nice medium personally when I'm shooting
something like at least 80% of my shots
are on a 50 and I just moved the camera
50 millimeter all the way I was
wondering how Wren got into VFX
and if he had any tips for 2009 I was on
my computer and I was using this website
called stumble upon stumbled upon this
website called Video Copilot dotnet and
I was like whoa that's interesting it
was this this demon face tutorial so I
watched the whole tutorial was like 40
minutes long I honestly didn't even know
you could do visual effects on your home
computer I only had a laptop at the time
so I ended up spending the next few
months watching every single tutorial on
that website when I should have probably
been studying that was how I got
individual effects I just watched a
whole crap ton of tutorials watch the
tutorials to figure out what buttons to
press but then come up with your own
ideas and figure out how to get from
point A to point B do little videos kind
of getting Bish's with your ideas when
you do that enough times you work on
enough videos suddenly your skill sets
getting big enough that you're like hey
I think I know how to do this now how do
you guys seem motivated to make content
even with all the roadblocks of
YouTube's current state staying
motivated in the YouTube atmosphere all
just comes down to forgetting about the
business aspects of it like forgetting
about trying to monetize your booze and
just just just just trying to make it
just about the video just to the
enjoyment of making good content that's
how I stay motivated and that's how we
we envision our content moving forwards
if you refresh your mind I recommend you
just listen to your instincts and your
urges if you feel like being lazy and
playing video games and be lazy and play
video games do you like traveling
getting out there go do it just listen
to your heart no because I've learned so
much more about it and I've learned that
there are other elements of filmmaking
that I enjoy more than what first got my
hands on the camera a lot of those
things I still enjoy but there's things
I enjoy even more what's a quarter of
goal for 2018 corridor goal for 2018 is
to shoot our very first movie make a
real newbie not some webseries not some
webisodes
make an actual movie
ice cream flavor OB hire cake pie all
day I'll even give you top 30 Apple
pumpkin and cheese cake is a cake it's
on a pie oh shoot I messed up that
answer Nick I think we finished it we've
finished the build and this is a
Frankenstein of a project I love it
this was the setup we rotate this back
and it should pull on all of them evenly
and they'll all fire at the same time
there's a considerably like far higher
degree of effort than I was expecting
well this is the minimum amount of
effort required for this to even work
they're all loaded right now yeah are
all loaded we're only ready to go this
is very well thought-out run so is this
how you imagined it this is better than
I imagined how you called me go so I
don't get hit in the teeth I've yet to
see it in action so maybe it's worse
than I imagined we'll find out what's
the real test is about - about to happen
some of these triggers have more play
than others so you have to just keep
pulling until they've all fired that's
my plan
I'm ready I'm ready Safety's ago all
right you ready in a three two
so this one fired six fired fired this
one did not so I think I know the
problem I I was trying to pull it just
from one point here what I need to do is
I need to pull it from two separate
points like this that was fantastic
I think we're done testing and I think
we can move on to actually shooting
people hey Ren who do you want to be
your first victim everyone should get in
front of the guns except for me because
I'm gonna pull the trigger everyone
except for you
who's gonna pull the trigger okay Ren
okay I haven't shot with so many bb's at
this point it's gonna be like a feather
just tickling me hey guys you got
something really cool to show you
backyard oh my god you rigged the whole
firing system oh my god alright everyone
get up there if it's not gonna be able
to kill multiple people at once then
what's the point
you know that's true I wouldn't feel
confident shooting it at somebody if I
didn't know what the damage was
do not take your masks off for any
reason even after the guns fire please
push it
Carmichael call it deaf you are my [ __ ]
lover yes should I get school really
good you go destroyed my iphone with an
arrow he forfeited burritos to everyone
we're gonna lose out on burritos
all right sorry I deal with some stuff
Nick honey I know a burrito can't
replace a well-baby the burrito can
replace opponents good enough right
yeah we make is a breed of expensive man
yeah there's no truck
that sucks had a chance to try out our
Metal Gear Solid game type where we
blind ourselves plug our ears and try
and sneak around the second video has
just been released on note if you guys
want to see how all this sub turned out
go check those videos out right now this
links all over the place than they
actually it turned out really really
well it was different than I expected
but it was really fun really funny and I
think it made some really good video so
check it out